Den head to Center Ice tipped to fiala for Deno
Doo down to the left Circle a shot kicked out by
Cal Peterson Shawn Walker on a dumping for
Philadelphia and the Kings through Center
dub down to the right Circle A backhander in
tight save Lewis trying to battle and get it
back cannot and the Flyers still looking to clear
turn it over lazat shoots save loose Puck covered
by Peterson who was trickling behind him and you
have the puck along watch this quickly come out
lazat and then he shoots right keep an eye on
the golender you know you're in trouble when he
thought he had it but he did get a good chance to
get the big glove on top of it the first move by
Peterson back glove on Puck line continues to do
some great work in in the four check and in the
last two games Kee heating up four goals in his
last five Atkinson Blue Line shot and for fiala
12 assists on the season ahead for Doo tipped
it on Save made Mo across on the right side off
Spence KV retrieves out to Spence with a shot
save made Peterson he missed though he couldn't
get the shot off that was a pretty solid chance
on a two-on-one dy's pass deflects to Moore Moore
in with a shot glove by Peterson Spence blocked
Puck out to Center ice and the Flyers take over
they go offside they had a player trapped as lton
moved in on the left wing taking advantage of the
minutes they get paling over the line a shot save
rebound save is made talit and a whistle oh two
good looks there for Philly very apparent there
outside watch this move pass goes a little one
right here because of the rebound that's all
you're trying to do nowadays has a letter on
his jersey alternate Captain Face Off to the left
of Cam Tel but an off the draw Walker a shot got
through to fiala back out two goals 12 assists
for Kevin moving down low stops up looks for a
Play Hands it off more couldn't take it England
does his shot blocked play ahead Lookout here's a
break tip it in decks and he scores just trickled
over the line Philadelphia starts the scoring we
see a little bit of the philosophy on the py
kill this is five on five but when the kings
were taking a shot watch the shot it doesn't go
through look at every two guys are going it ends
up being tipping and when he goes to the back
end just a piece just enough but two guys are
going as the shot from the Kings is taking
place and you see it just gets seven hole
there I believe just under the arm of talet as
he moving across but Lane up the middle of the
ice when the shot was blocked by Walker early
on the Kings had the shots on goal Advantage
but the Flyers have turned the table and a second
and third period total they've got a total of 24
goals for off the draw gabri off a shot block
pu still alive lazat to the trailer Roy ran
into traffic look out play ahead onside here's
a great Flyers get a chance and a save is made
the bid the so-called second unit one- nothing
Philly period winding down behind the Ned Den
know in front to Kia couldn't pull the trigger
on it more a chance block Spence with it right
side to kempe four goals in his last five to dowy
to kempe with a blast sa Peterson had a good look
at that they'll set it up now with kempe for
kop to dub shot pass TI on loose pu fala can't
bury it K can't Flyers will send it around hard
and get it down Al in the offensive zone there's
that tip I was talking about just throw it down
low stick on the ice and there's the save Daryl
was talking about Cal comes across and he gets
that leg pad all that skill but he has to be on
edge to be effective 41 goals last year after
a 30 plus goal season two years ago shot left
Circle dou across the Byfield pass behind him
Kopitar settles it for kempe and out to dowy
a shot say big rebound Trevor Moore Moore got
stood up inside the Philadelphia line checked
by Nick sealer and here is Philadelphia Frost
driving wide threw it in front they score went
off I think one of the Kings and the Flyers have
a two nothing lead yeah this is not a surprise
here at least the way this period's been going
the Flyers seem seem to have just a little bit
more jump they seem to be anticipating just a
little bit more tala comes way out watch this
way out of the net and look at this on this move
right here he's going one way and there it is you
off the skates of Spence perhaps off T but again
Frost probably isn't trying this but he senses
there's trouble he senses that the golender is
caught on one side of the net so even if it's
not clean just get it to that area will be danger
steady here tonight the X King by field out to Roy
a shot def Flex wide loose Puck side of the
net Kopitar couldn't bang it home Kee curls
shot block Kings with a decisive Advantage Kings
out shooting their opponents on a regular basis
you'd expect that from a good team kkny driving
wide he's behind the net looking for a play conne
feeds it up top sealer a shot they score tipped in
front Frost might have his second of the game and
it's three nothing Philadelphia all right here
the Flyers are able to get guys into that home
plate area to the point and then very quickly with
a shot but watch where Frost doesn't even leave he
stays right there look at 48 he's watching he's
facing the shooter gets his stick free the Flyers
actually outnumbering the Kings two to one down
low there exactly in the high danger inner slot
area so the overall numbers continue to be for the
Kings a spence shot is blocked Kings adjusting two
of lines here tonight after keeping the same
combinations for 11 straight games as runstrom
scores I think that shot went off a defenseman
kings are on the board Carl grundstrom his sixth
goal two- goal deficit regrouped by the Kings
it really doesn't look dangerous here you could
see that brunstrom was calling for the puck Cal
kind of lunges at it there's a couple of demand
to me Nick it looks like like it goes between
them but you can tell by the reaction to C oh
get a good look right here it goes just inside
the legs of Walker and then inside the arm seven
hole and the Kings will retreat they get CV out
now CV playing with new line mates tonight as is
fiala now look out a turnover gof was pressured
cier centers shot and they score Atkinson taking
advantage of mismanaging the puck by the Kings
and it's 41 Philadelphia and the Flyers just keep
it going here the Kings have possession and then
the strip it's gabov that stripped and it just it
took a while to get going but then again after the
strip the Kings don't recognize the most dangerous
area in the game so I think darl if there's a
difference in this game gabov for kobitar sends
it across CR Spence a shot blocked Flyers doing
a marvelous job in that regard blocking shots
in front it comes TI score Kee got a touch pass
from Byfield Adrien K's fifth goal in the last
six games 4-2 Spence that kind of open things
up and then the Flyers never have right there
that's when you want to get it out you know this
is a nice redirection here here's the play I was
talking about this from this point on I think
this really opened things up it did not get it
going right away but the Kings continue to chase
down pucks the fly's unable to clear and I think
it was Byfield with a nice touch check Flyers will
clear it down dowy back and that's going to do it
so the Kings win in Philly last week Philly wins
in LA tonight ex King Cal Peterson gets the win